Yo! C'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce Coup de Phil'
Vous avez comme tout le monde un besoin de reconnaissance
et pour ça, vous allez devoir vous confronter à l'autre
mais est-ce que vous êtes sûr de gagner cette confrontation?
pour répondre à cette question et comprendre un peu mieux ce que je raconte
on va parler de la Dialectique du Maître
et de l'Esclave
d'Hegel
George Wilhelm Friedrich Hegel est un philosophe
allemand du XIXè siècle
et non, je ne ferai pas de blague sur son nom de famille…
Ferme t'Hegel !
Ouf, ça fait du bien
Ah !
Sa philosophie est très riche et très complète,
il fait partie de ceux qui ont voulu unifier
tout le savoir de leur temps en un vrai système philosophique
où tout les systèmes sont interdépendants
un peu à la Aristote ou à la Thomas d'Acquin
et il y a un élément qui est très important dans son œuvre
c'est la dialectique… Hégélienne
Pour comprendre ce qu'est la dialectique prenons les stades
d'un Pokémon. Ici le stade Salamèche
le stade Réptincel est l'évolution du stade Salamèche
Donc quand vous obtenez le stade Réptincel,
vous n'avez plus votre stade Salamèche
Réptincel est la fin de Salamèche
dans les deux sens du terme. C'est à dire que
c'est un but, une finalité, et en même temps
Salamèche n'existe plus vraiment
quand Réptincel arrive. C'est sa fin.
C'est pareil quand Réptincel évolue en Dracofeu
En fait, pendant une évolution, on a trois choses
une négation: Dracofeu supprime Réptincel
une conservation: Réptincel
continue dans Dracofeu en terme d'A.D.N.,
d'âme ou de souvenirs par exemple
et un dépassement. Dracofeu c'est un Réptincel dépassé.
Et ce processus là ça s'appelle Aufhebung
Je ne le dis pas en allemand pour me la péter ou quoi,
c'est juste qu'on n'a pas l'équivalent en français
alors on pourrait parler du mot "relève" peut-être
en tout cas ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que c'est la signature de cette dialéctique
C'est le même processus pour les plan de philo' qui font
thèse, anti-thèse, synthèse. Et Hegel c'est un ouf avec ça
tout tourne autour de la dialéctique
Y'a trois grandes parties dans sa philosophie,
dans chacune des parties il y a trois œuvres,
et dans ses livres il y a trois parties, et dans chaque partie,
il y a trois chapitres, etc.
Hegel, ça fait une heure qu'on attend que tu commandes
Oui, mais ce n'est que entrée-plat ou plat-dessert
moi je veux entrée, plat et dessert. Aufenbung!
Prends une pizza quatre fromages!
On ne peut pas en enlever un?
Elle a raison, dépêche-toi,
sinon on ne le fera jamais ce plan à trois
Alors effectivement, vous avez bien trois couilles!
Alors vous allez voir, c'est un peu plus corsé que d'habitude,
n'hésitez pas à abuser du bouton "pause", hein,
parce que vous êtes un spéctateur "actif" de la vidéo, ok.
Y'a une métaphore qui arrive pour mieux comprendre.
Donc chez Hegel entre deux stades d'une dialectique
il y a des relations de négations
donc il y a toujours des relations entre les opposés
d'où cette citation: on ne se pose qu'en s'opposant
"On se pose" dans le sens où on se définit
Les choses se déterminent par négations
Être soi, c'est aussi être ce qu'on n'est pas ou ce qu'on n'est plus.
Ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que si on était dans un principe d'identité,
c'est à dire si on n'avait pas de contraire en nous
et qu'on avait tout le temps genre: "A = A"
et bien il ne se passerait rien
Il n'y aurait jamais de changement et jamais de mouvement
Et donc si on se définit par négation
le "moi" n'a de sens qu'en tant qu'il n'est pas autrui
et ça c'est super intéressant par rapport à notre conscience de soi
parce que ça veut dire que pour Hegel l'existance d'autrui
est indispensable à la conscience de soi.
Je ne prends conscience de moi
que par la prise de conscience de l'autre
et lui va encore plus loin puisque pour lui la connaissance de soi
passe par la reconnaissance de soi
par l'autre
Bonjour, comment vous-vous appelez?
Alors, je ne m'appelle pas:
Adolf, Alban,
Alexander, Albrecht…
Valentin,
Victor,
Voldemort
Willy Wonka
Alors, vous avez trouvé quel prénom il manque?
Pour nous faire un peu mieux comprendre ce qu'il se passe,
Hegel va utiliser une métaphore qui est la métaphore du maître et de l'esclave
Alors on ne parle pas vraiment de deux individus mais
plus de deux consiences. Quand les deux se rencontrent,
les deux ont ce désir de reconnaissance
c'est un désir qui nous distingue de l'animal
et qu'on a tous plus ou moins fort
Et les deux vont tenter d'avoir la reconnaissance de l'autre,
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que pour Hegel il ne peut pas y avoir d'égalité
du coup il va y avoir une lutte entre les deux consciences
Et s'il n'y a pas de lutte, c'est que les deux personnes
n'existent pas encore l'une pour l'autre, elles ne cherchent pas encore la reconnaissance de l'autre
C'est genre deux personnes qui se croisent dans la rue
Voilà donc je viens de croiser une personne
qui s'en branle complètement de ma gueule. Je n'existe pas pour cette personne
Putain du coup y'a peut-être moyen de gagner un abonné
Excusez-moi!
Quand il y a lutte, les deux sujets vont essayer de s'asservir l'un et l'autre
c'est à dire de nier l'a conscience de l'autre
dans un "combat à mort", mais sans tuer l'autre parce que sinon la conscience qui reste
n'est reconnue par personne
Et d'ailleurs quand Hegel dit "combat à mort"
c'est une façon de parler: le but c'est une neutralisation
de l'autre en tant que rival. Mais c'est une métaphore.
Et Hegel imagine une première conscience,
la conscience 1 qui va "risquer sa vie"
c'est à dire qu'elle va risque de ne pas être reconnue
elle va affirmer son désir de reconnaissance jusqu'au bout
Elle a faim, quoi.
Et une autre conscience qui refuse de la risquer
qui veut juste "vivre sa life" de son coté et qui n'a pas un désir très fort.
La conscience 1 se montre le maître de la conscience 2
On est dans une situation de domination
C'est le maître… et l'esclave.
C'est la première étape de la dialéctique
et en gros c'est le stade Salamèche
Sauf que le truc c'est que maintenant l'esclave taffe comme un ouf pour le maître
Il fait des choses, il travaille la nature
Alors que le maître lui est complètement dépendant de l'esclave
Et en plus il est reconnu par quelqu'un
qu'il ne reconnait même pas!
La consience 2 se montre maître de la vie par son travail,
la conscience 1 se montre dépendante de la conscience 2
donc la conscience 1 s'est rendue esclave de l'esclave
Il y a une inversion: c'est la seconde étape de la dialéctique
En gros c'est le stade Réptincel
Donc au final on a un esclave qui est devenu maître
Et un maître qui est devenu esclave
Les deux consciences réalisent ensemble que domination et servitude ne sont pas enviable
Chacun a eu sa reconnaissance,
il y a donc une annulation de la relation maître-esclave
C'est la dernière étape de la dialéctique
C'est donc le stade Dracofeu
Et ils eurent beaucoup d'enfants
Alors il est possible que cette dialéctique du maître et de l'esclave
elle vous rappelle plusieurs choses parce qu'on peut la transposer à plein de trucs
par exemple des relations professeur-élèves
enfant-parent
des relations de couple
employeur-salarié
et même ça nous rappelle la lutte des classes de Marx
Et c'est normal parce que cette dialéctique a eu une grande influence sur lui
Maintenant en attendant qu'on passe au stade deux de cette dialectique
je reste votre serviteur et j'ai besoin de reconnaissance
donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner et à partager cette vidéo
On se retrouve dans 2 semaines, jeudi 18h,
je vous envoie du love et de la peace.